a company with a vision to transport
people at near supersonic speed is
announcing what it calls an historic
achievements Hyperloop one is building
what could be the next mode of
high-speed transportation passengers
will be loaded onto pods that will
travel through a tube at 700 miles an
hour that is faster than the speed of a
Boeing passenger jet first on CBS this
morning here's a look at the first
private test of the Hyperloop it took
place in the Nevada desert three two one
fire
[Music]
the company now says it has the first
full-scale Hyperloop in the world
Hyperloop ones goal is to have three
systems in service by 2021 co-founders
Josh goggle and Shervin peshkov are are
here good morning to both of you for
having us pretty exciting it was a
high-five and Danny overture people have
been looking into this to popularize in
mainstream this form of transportation
for a while why do you think you have it
right now well we have it because we did
it and we've been working so hard Josh
goggle my co-founder and I and the whole
team in two and a half years from idea
to reality Hyperloop is real the video
you saw is our Kittyhawk moment we take
a lot of inspiration from the Wright
brothers and wanted to show the world
that it works this is the first
full-scale Hyperloop in the world the
structure weighs 2 million pounds we did
the levitation the propulsion and the
full-scale vacuum as if you're creating
your own sky in the tube flying at
20,000 feet will be the safest cleanest
fastest form of transportation in the
world serve and I love the the Kitty
Hawk moment that you explained and Josh
tell us the experience what excites me
about it is that you can go from LA to
San Francisco in 30 minutes yeah but why
should I not be terrified at being in a
tube underground so I mean we get in the
tube every day we got a tube yesterday
to come to either here in the subway
we're playing and you know being on
inside this tunnel or the tube is ours
as we call it we don't have any real
concerns about the in the event of
emergency so you can basically get out
if there's an emergency just like you
would in a tunnel and you're not at
30,000 feet so you have the ability not
to I can get out and go where Josh I'm
underground where am I going
just like when you're driving a tunnel
or in your subway there's emergency evac
ports but not so it's not going 700
miles an hour yeah right but we're able
to slow down we have emergency braking
techniques things that we've been
testing and that allows us in the event
that something were to happen you're
able to slow down safely sure and I know
you guys have an ambitious goal of
creating three functioning Hyperloop
blue units in like four years
how Hays for it right that's a great
question or
we need the support of people and
governments around the world you can't
build hyper loops around the world
without the support of governments we
think of this as a form of
transportation a new form of
transportation like broadband so
high-speed transportation will be very
similar to that in the same way the
government's adopted broadband around
the world and mobile we need their
support to do it and we're having
amazing contacts and communications and
partnerships with governments already
you need the land right that's right the
the right of ways are extremely
important and building new
infrastructure for the world is so
important we're all stuck in traffic it
causes so much pain and waste so much
time for people speeding things up
making cities into metro stops being
able to go like Gale said from SF to LA
in 3035 minutes is game-changing it
changes the way we think about where we
live where we work Washington to New
York you see that Trevin happening
absolutely the the Northeast Corridor is
a is a huge focus for us and being able
to go that fast will allow everyone that
kind of spread around live and work
wherever they want and it'll change the
reason what about the rest of the
country there's so much of this
conversation sometimes just focuses on
the east and west coast I mean mid the
middle the country I mean you want to
bring this everywhere yeah there's
there's a few spots that we've been
looking in Texas as well as Florida part
of our Hyperloop line global challenge
which was looking at different areas
around the world and then last really
three or four months engaged with quite
a few of the local governments on where
these potential projects can be so what
are you worried about sure and listen I
know you love your mom your sister your
favorite daughter
nephew Donovan's in the in the room here
there has to be something that you think
well we're kind of worried about this or
this isn't going to plan well it has to
be some concerns it sounds great I love
all the high five Kittyhawks all that
but what are you concerned about now
that's a great question the number one
concern is is to make this idea a
reality and this was a huge step in
showing the world today on this show
that this this is real we've done it and
now is to really go to the next stage of
as Nora said connecting with the
governments in action
building working hyper loops around the
world people have the courage to put
this in place yes mover work on changing
transportation in America that's right
I think if you had the chance to be
around when the Wright brothers tested
at Kitty Hawk like this is what what we
had so it's really for an engineer it's
super exciting well it's exciting I'm
sure those of us that travel allow us
yeah yeah we wish you the best of luck
thank you so much thank you which is all
of us you know everybody's traveling a
lot to and from work yeah safety and
speed you can't beat that
congratulations thank you ventilations
Josh goggle and Sherman the shebar